[Music]
in harvest news Harless heartless
heartless like no heart oh oh they got
their heart taken out yeah yeah less
than 3 News submitted by Ashley hi
Ashley that's the most normal well we
have yeah it's not like I like [ __ ]
alright
I like [ __ ] Dunkin Donuts workers
have been suspended over dumping water
on a sleeping homeless man what's the
context
give me the content what's the other
side of the story what did that bastard
say that maybe there's no explanation
for this pity smell and they were trying
to give him a little bit little bit
little bit okay you win could have been
speaking in devil tongues and then he
they had to baptize them with don't
nothin doing that holy water baptized
yeah so this this takes place in
Syracuse New York where witches were
close by by the way cuz Salem has a lot
of witches in Salem Florida yeah anyway
so then this is the video that went
viral I was a video awesome okay you get
your answer here like how they record it
as if it was okay that's awesome exactly
so these two guys they work here here we
go oh no they're just laughing he was
charging his phone - dude that's so mean
oh he doesn't mean clothes to change
into in their lives or something thank
God he had a hoodie on
enough time man how many times until
customers and the people gonna tell you
to stop sleeping here no it was an
accident
you gonna get out of here he's like it
was an accident I know he's not even
trying to fight or anything users like
sorry maybe these guys really needed
content you guys aren't thinking of that
I thought he was just a regular guy like
the way he looked like yeah he doesn't
look homeless a lot of homeless people
don't well maybe he's trying to get his
act together maybe he's like trying
really hard that's like the backpack
guys they don't look homeless but they
got backpacks oh it's like technically
that guy is like doing quote-unquote his
job right because but not to pour water
on ice in there dude
he's doing his job but he's like the
dumbass that doesn't know the boundaries
within it I mean it's like a want to
throw out the trash like cool he takes a
matching license on fire yeah it's like
we talked about it's just gonna
disintegrate nothing well these are the
people who love to assert themselves
like you know I'm saying like where it's
like you're like the mall security guy
or it's like I never got to be a cop
yes but I want to serve my authority
like this is my thing I mean if he does
that as a Dunkin Donuts employee imagine
what would happen if he was a cop I do
right I don't want to imagine I kind of
do but I got I hurry up you know how
long it takes to fill up a bucket of
water long time he had a solid minute
and I have to think about what he was
doing like did he and the guys recording
nude and Inez did the recording was like
someone that he knew wasn't gonna fight
back obviously if that guy's fallen
asleep there before he knows that this
guy is not an aggressive dude yeah
because if that was Kimbo Slice you
would have you would have uh
second-guessed yourself right there
wouldn't you ever I like that he thinks
he's the good guy though he's like yeah
it was like he said what we'll do is
we'll focus bump kind of water I will
dump it on his [ __ ] head
back you get on up out of here that's
the good guy right was it he thinks
everyone's gonna go yeah got the bomb
out yeah when we post this footage
everybody you guys are the good guys and
what the funny part is like he was like
I keep on tell you keep bothering all
these customers where I see anybody and
it's a Dunkin Donuts bro nobody [ __ ]
cares Dunkin Donuts should be a safe
haven for people yeah Duncan I was in
McDonald's Taco Bell those are the good
place nobody get that Taco Bell now
let's not go crazy here not talking
about excuse me we should just let any
riffraff security at home that's too
close to home for man exactly wait so
you're on the side of employees kicking
out riffraff it will the Taco Bell be a
little bit it's a woman I don't care you
would've brought the bucket yeah I don't
care if bums are inside or whatever but
it's the it's the guys that are a little
crazy yeah that start fighting the
customers or if they are like yeah well
you're like it's gotta chose to do their
and they're going like this or whatever
and it's like oh yeah we can't have we
don't know what he's gonna do cuz if the
dude is like sleepy any smells fine I'm
okay yeah cuz sometimes when I'm eating
sometimes they smell a certain yeah they
ruined your food I'm like trouble yeah
swallowing my food but then there are
people in life where I'm like this guy
always smells always every time I see
this person and those people said
they're not even bums they should get
kicked ass dude complaint on everyone
right so did they get fired so there is
suspended as like suspended yeah as they
investigate would happen investigator
that's how they reporting you gonna have
an eternal investigation yeah so the man
his name is Jeremy and he suffers from
schizophrenia and Hugh said that she was
at the Dunkin Donuts to charge his cell
phone so you could call his mother to
say good night
oh no and well I mean did he buy stuff
cuz if you bought a donut or whatever
then no matter what they're in the wrong
yeah it doesn't seem like you did
so I don't know anything it's considered
loitering you know what I mean so like
that's the loophole is like you know
they should just buy like a 50 cent
coffee or whatever coffee is nowadays a
dollar I don't know it's like it is mine
too from what I remember what he said he
was like I'm not gonna call a cop so
maybe in his mind he thought he was
doing him a favor but now he's gotta go
outside in New York with wet clothes
like the weather is not kind to you yeah
it's crazy how I I have this guy's back
but if this was in the middle of a
Starbucks and it's just a bunch of
people on their Apple laptops and some
guy's got a hose and employees got a
hose and all going like pick up their
[ __ ] cuz I just can't stand that [ __ ]
whatever I'm going to Starbucks I'm like
oh my god how many [ __ ] people I
can't sit down even for five seconds
because all you guys are posted yeah
what is that what is the thing about
writing scripts at a Starbucks is that
why why I used to go to Starbucks to
write scripts but it was because they
had outlets and they had Wi-Fi they have
free Wi-Fi and this was back in like
2011 and it was walking distance from my
house if there were any other cafes I
had outlets and Wi-Fi and would let you
post up I will just I work on there too
I will say you're a gold member which I
may or may not have been they gave you
free refills yeah I was a gold member
what's a gold member well back in the
day you got it well I have a gold card
actually you want to see yeah we need
proof well so you used to get hella
rewards now they took away like a lot of
the reward but used to get free milk
choices so I would always get almond
milk and then you got free flavor
choices so I gave it free vanilla in my
vanilla latte and then you got like free
refills
oh you guys wasn't legit huh kind of
cool some women like to keep you emo on
there what does it get you
it says Nikki what why didn't we use it
today things I said it what we do use it
now but now it's on the app so it has a
picture of it on there and there's a
picture oh yeah they used to give solid
cards and didn't used to show it on the
App boost you know what's so weird I've
never wanted something so bad in my life
that's so stupid but now I'm like can I
have it you do money to the man David
dude I didn't think I went to Starbucks
that often but I signed up for the
reward thing and then next thing I know
is a Goldmember like [ __ ] it come here
wait I mean I was broke as [ __ ] at that
time I don't know how I got gold is
there so much oh you got both cuz you
spent it all on Starbucks that's right
but yeah so now people that saw this
video they created a GoFundMe for oh my
god yes there's gonna be a scandal
dude there's too many golf bunnies well
as of now you're against his Mangan the
GoFundMe oh you know what people need to
do they need a GoFundMe more
institutions that can help people with
disabilities yeah because there's a lot
of veterans with PTSD so that's how
charities started but then they get all
corrupt because once they start making
money the people in charge are like [ __ ]
heads and they just not all charities
make you know you have to really do
research though like the main ones like
like breast cancer the you know that one
yeah that one's off [ __ ] and the
there's tough like a lot of them are all
fat red crotch right I could sit here
and agree that every single Cancer
Association is a corrupt piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
really money there me tell you what's
gonna go well but there are like smaller
organizations that help with cancer that
you should donate to used to do research
so don't give to the bigger ones there's
actual proof like a look at their
financial statements look at like where
the money went and also looked at what
they lobby for what kind of [ __ ] they
shut down like it was it was like the
three biggest [ __ ] cancer Association
in breast cancer baby shut down people
getting a discount for living a
healthier life yes and and they their
argument was they hid under the guise of
well you know poor people can't afford
healthy food and gym membership and
stuff like that so it's not fair for
them yeah because they wanted to give
people medical discounts and all that
stuff for living a healthier life and
promoting oh yeah but what if you get
rid of cancer than then they're out of a
job exactly that's solution absolutely
love keeping people in cancer and then
they've been around for like how many
years since all their business this is
what they always do they go hey we need
more money we just if only we have ten
million more dollars then we can solve
this
they haven't [ __ ] done [ __ ] where they
have made some crazy steps toward like
with cancer rate especially even
recently in the past couple months but
those are a lot of those stuff that I've
seen is from these smaller private
Institute's yeah the private like direct
to the organization like not not the
ones that go to paying salaries for the
[ __ ] corporate leaders yeah but if
you look it up you'll see that they like
yet they raised thirty million dollars
but they gave eighteen thousand dollars
to cancer research yeah yeah people I'm
talking about [ __ ] those guys
[Music]